l'hôtel de ville de Saint-Pierre
au début du 18e siècle la Compagnie des
Indes impose la culture du café dans
toute l'île afin de stocker les
précieuses récoltes destinales à
l'exportation vers la France des
entrepôts sont construits près des
principaux points d'embarquement
bâtiment administratifs et magasins
voient notamment le jour dans la ville
naissant de Saint-Pierre à l'embouchure
de la rivière d'abord
le vaste édifice qui accueille les
services municipaux depuis 1825 et bâti
non loin de là
construit en 1770 il sert à l'origine
d'entrepôts et de bureau d'où l'absence
de tout décor architectural considéré
comme superflu
aux extrémités de la partie centrale
deux ailes forment un léger ressaut des
tailles caractéristiques de
l'architecture française du XVIIIe
siècle
conçue en moelleux recouvert d'un enduit
à la chaux il est surmonté d'une haute
toiture à quatre pans recouverte de
Bardo lors de sa transformation en hôtel
de ville on ajoute au-dessus de l'entrée
un beffroi et un fronton encadré
d'élégante volutes pour lui donner un
caractère plus officiel son plan massé
ses volumes et sa toiture inscrivent ce
monument d'une grande sobriété dans la
continuité stylistique des premiers
édifices publics réunionnais du XVIIIe
siècle
située de part et d'autre d'un escalier
monumental les pièces de stockage ont
été divisées en bureau seul subsiste à
l'étage une salle accueillant les
séances du conseil municipal
l'hôtel de ville de Saint-Pierre a été
classé au titre des Monuments
Historiques en 1982